kim kardashian is officially a single
woman
oh my god
on wednesday the reality star's petition
to be declared legally single amid her
divorce proceedings with kanye west was
granted the ruling means kim will drop
west from her last name but does not
mean her divorce is final in a nutshell
kim's marital status will now be single
while she continues to work out a
divorce settlement with a 44 year old
rapper it's a different experience for
sure
the judge made the ruling wednesday
morning in court where the 41 year old
skims founder gave a short testimony via
zoom kim told the court everyone is
doing okay and when asked if she's
showering her kids with affection
she replied absolutely
in court documents obtained by e.t last
month kim says she does very much desire
to be divorced adding that kanye has
been putting out a lot of misinformation
about their private matters and
co-parenting arrangement on social media
which has caused kim emotional distress
i do have a family that i have to just
be positive and get it together for of
course all this comes after a tumultuous
february which saw yay hurl a series of
accusations at kim on instagram you know
social media is such a great tool but of
course you need boundaries i think
everyone does
including that she didn't provide the
address for their daughter chicago's
birthday party put security on him when
he was playing with his son had him take
a drug test after the party and that
their eldest daughter north is on
tick-tock against his will
don't have my daughter
wearing lipstick
on tick tock i don't have on tic tac at
all
if i'm not going to approve that
[Music]
a source told e.t back in january that
kim was upset by kanye's antics which
also included several social media posts
trashing kim's new beau pete davidson
god sent me from the crash
just so i could beat pete david
well last week yay made a last-ditch
effort to stop his estranged wife's wish
to be declared legally single filing
legal docs that slammed kim's claims
that he'd been putting out
misinformation stating that she can't
prove he was the one behind those social
media posts
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
meanwhile kim who filed for divorce from
kanye back in february 2021 after six
years of marriage had been adamant that
being declared legally single will help
kanye accept that their marital
relationship is over so they can move
forward on a better path
kim says this will help them peacefully
co-parent their four children
[Music]
you